hamlin pour le groupe l'est républicain
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
je veux revenir sur l'urgence libyenne
je vais revenir sur cette situation qui
n'est plus seulement une menace mais un
danger imminent déclaré réel pour notre
sécurité collective
la libye est devenue la base arrière du
jihadisme et elle vise directement notre
sécurité comme elle affecte la
transition déjà fragile des pays de la
région les récents attentats qui
viennent de frapper la tunisie dont nous
sommes naturellement tout à fait
solidaire ainsi que la stabilité des
pays de la région qu'il ne faut pas
oublier rappelle s'il en était besoin
que nous avons avec la croissance de
dèche un risque nouveau tout à fait
déterminant aux portes de l'europe
nous pouvions imaginer que précisément
la présence de deux réveils ray
positivement le nationalisme libyen et
éteindre et les rivalités locales
ce n'est pas le cas et aujourd'hui
malheureusement le gouvernement d'unité
nationale reste une fiction légale alors
que sa validation institutionnel est
nécessaire à la légitimité et à
l'efficacité de toutes actions
internationales politiques économiques
voire militaire je vous demande monsieur
le premier ministre
quelles sont les initiatives politiques
immédiates que compte vendre la france
aux côtés de la communauté
internationale et de la mission kobler
pour consolider le processus politique
et institutionnelle qui s'impose comme
une véritable urgence l'union européenne
face au conflit syrien et à la crise
migratoire n'a pas fait la preuve ni
d'autorité ni l'organisation ni
d'anticipation dit de coordination
peut-on espérer au lendemain du sommet
de venise que nous allons corriger cette
trajectoire si je puis dire dans
l'intérêt même de la france et des états
européens
pouvons-nous imaginer aussi que les
états européens forment avec l'italie et
le sud de l'europe
une mission une task force je dirais
européenne qui pourrait utilement
prendre le leadership sur cette partie
de la méditerranée
simone où l'on voit naître
malheureusement l'après-vol à nouveau
complet monsieur le secrétaire d'état
aux affaires européennes monsieur harlem
désir
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés madame la députée
nicole ameline comme vous venez de le
rappeler comme vient de le dire le
ministre de la défense
la situation en libye est effectivement
l'objet de toute notre attention parce
qu'elle a un impact sur la sécurité de
la région en particulier sur la tunisie
mais aussi sur les pays du sahel et
parce qu'elle peut représenter une
menace pour l'europe le groupe dès
aujourd'hui prospère notamment autour de
la ville de syrte
il profite de l'absence d'état unitaire
en libye il profite de l'absence d'unité
du peuple libyen et donc vous avez
raison de rappeler que la priorité de la
france comme de la communauté
internationale c'est la constitution
d'un gouvernement d'union nationale en
libye et nous soutenons les efforts du
médiateur des nations unies monsieur
kobler pour aboutir à la constitution de
ce gouvernement qui a d'ores et déjà
reçu le soutien d'un très grand nombre
de parlementaires de l'assemblée de
tobrouk même si celle ci n'a pas pu se
rate sur se réunir et ce gouvernement
doit pouvoir s'installer à tripoli
récupérer la souveraineté sur
l'intégralité du territoire libyen et
avoir l'appui de la communauté
internationale et en particulier de la
france et de ses partenaires européens
le ministre des affaires étrangères jean
marc ayrault dès sa nomination a
rencontré à munich
les principaux homologues des pays
concernés et le représentant des nations
unies
hier lors de la rencontre entre le
président de la république et le
président du conseil italien matteo
renzi la france et l'italie ont décidé
évidemment de renforcer leur coopération
sur ce sujet qui concernent directement
notre sécurité et dimanche à paris le
ministre des affaires étrangères recevra
avec john kerry les représentants de
l'allemagne de la grande bretagne de
l'italie de l'union européenne et ce
sujet sera évidemment à l'ordre du jour
il faut donc absolument que tous les
acteurs qui ont une influence sur l'aide
sur la libye en particulier un certain
nombre de pays de la région fassent
pression sur les libyens pour qu'il y
ait ce gouvernement d'union nationale et
que la communauté internationale sont
évidemment prête à tout faire pour
empêcher que le groupe lâche ne prenne
le contrôle de la libye
merci monsieur le ministre
la parole est à monsieur bertrand pas